the jurogan experience speaking spoilers
you've seen the new batman yes i saw
that it's great i liked it i liked it
besides i mean the dark knight is the
best of all time but to me that i was
halfway through i looked at my girl
because you know like we have kids can't
go to the movies like my girl i go i
pause hold up is this not the best
[ __ ] batman you've seen it's a great
batman it's so good i thought it was the
best one but it's up there i'm i say
that and then i need to go like watch
the other ones
again you know like with fresh eyes like
sometimes when something's good you're
watching it yeah oh this is pretty good
you might get on the hype train the
costumes are a little wack you think see
i thought it was more realistic like yes
it wasn't like
like at least catwoman like she owned
cats yeah she wasn't gonna be like she
died nine times she barely covered her
face yeah
she was too hot and we just didn't want
to like cover any of her face just like
a little tiny thing of course
yeah but then i showed the most of her
face the riddler the really
with the glasses yeah really see
the riddler to me was so creepy because
you know it's he's like
you know he he like relate to all the
incels and like this mob and like you
know bring him to the [ __ ] stadium
and shoot everybody it's like yeah that
could definitely the problem with all
those movies is you compare them all
against the joker and the joker movie
was so [ __ ] good and so creepy like
and and
you know the dark knight you're saying
with uh yeah heath ledger well no the
the recent one with uh with joaquin
phoenix yeah that joker is so good yeah
but it's so creepy and such a good movie
todd phillips just [ __ ] nailed that
movie and so did and joaquin phoenix is
crazy as [ __ ] he's so good he's so good
he must be insane he might he must be
like an absolute insane person there's
no way he could be that good playing in
the same person
it's so good but the point is like
though that movie is so goddamn good and
the the bad
you know the characters so believable
and they build it up so well
like it's hard to appreciate some of the
like you don't know the riddler's
background this also needs a bad guy but
if we knew as much about
the joker like much about the riddlers
we'd do the joker
and then they had that in the batman
movie like if they have a new batman
movie with
joaquin phoenix as the joker oh that's
going to be insane did you see the new
joker like they so they flashed them
just at the very end spoiler they splash
they they literally just flashed them
right at the end yeah so it's but it's
kind of blurry but on hbo max there's a
deleted scene
and it's him with like the joke for like
six minutes and dude [ __ ] it's good oh
really it's good a deleted scene with
just him and the joker yes
it's very like uh science of the lambs
remember where they use hannibal to like
hannibal lecter to catch the other
[ __ ] serial killers
batman goes to him to give him the
riddler found like i know you get off on
the [ __ ] maybe can help me out
and who is the joke who plays the joker
i don't know
but it's good man i like how most of the
people were like people that you don't
know their name yes you know other than
robert pattinson most of the people were
people you don't know like you don't
know the penguin's name but he's called
phil that was colin pharaoh yeah how
nuts is that jesus christ really not
nuts you know what i actually knew that
i forgot it that's how good he is right
oh my god the makeup is incredible nuts
dude think about the batmobile
batmobile's pretty dope that's uh that
you know what that's sorry i saw the
batmobile i'm like look at that nuts
that's incredible man
anyways
what did they do with him
yeah
dude that that car scene with him and
that that batmobile if you look up the
batmobile that's actually the chassis of
an old school dodge challenger yeah i
heard about that yeah that thing's legit
yeah old school dodge challenger and
then they did a bunch of like off-road
[ __ ] buy one dude
[ __ ] get one seems like it's a wide
thing to park
difficult to find dude in austin you'll
be fine l.a i'd be [ __ ] here you're
good dude maybe
you're good i don't need that in my life
no it seems like a lot it'd be fun
yeah i got enough cars you wouldn't feel
like an [ __ ] on that one it wouldn't
you think no it's so loud yeah i feel
like i should have saw my chevelle do
you in the chevelle wow it's so loud
it's but it's it you know the world's
turning to [ __ ] teslas man in
electric cars
yeah but not totally like this is why
it's fun right now to have like a muscle
car because it's like you know that this
is like the light it's like going out
when you're 36
and you're still single it's like this
is the last days
this is it
it is wow look at that no that's not it
that's not it dude someone made one well
someone made one no but this one's
actually a chassis off a [ __ ] like 68
challenger i think yeah that one looks
more like christian bales batman i like
the tumbler like that like this
or whatever yeah
that was dope that was the christian
bale one the one with two wheels in the
front but the one that uh robert
pattinson has is much more like
realistic
that's right there it's right above
right above go above above right there
in the toy no the toy go next to it go
next to it go next to it no the second
one watch my finger right there that
click on that
that's that's a toy but that's what it
is that's what it looks like that's off
old school chassis of a dodge chip
challenger might be a dodge charger
either way it looks like a charger
yeah it's so dumb i think it's a charger
but it's um
it was cool like the whole movie was
dark and mysterious and shadowy and
it was fun emo yeah a little emo little
emo yeah but it was it worked
it worked